ليبيا ساحه صراع على النفوذ بين واشنطن
وموسكو فبينما تفكر امريكا في اعاده فتح
سفاراتها في ليبيا يستعد سفير روسيا
الجديد بالفعل لتولي منصبه الجديد في
طرابلس النفط مصدر الجذب الاساسي للقوى
العالميه حسب بلومبرج فمجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه تمتلك بالفعل امكانيه الوصول الى
منشات النفط الرئيسيه في ليبيا كما ان
قرار موسكو باعاده ترسيخ وجودها
الدبلوماسي في طرابلس غربي البلاد اوضح
مؤشر حتى الان على ان بوتين يتطلع الى
تحقيق تقدم يتجاوز دعمه التقليدي للجيش
الليبي
التحركات الروسيه في ليبيا غدت مصدر قلق
كبير لامريكا التي ارسلت عددا من كبار
المسؤولين بينهم رئيس وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه
لمواجهه الدوري الروسي الذي احرزه بوتين
في احد
الذي تتودد اليه الحكومات الاوروبيه كبديل
محتمل للطاقه الروسيه
يتصدر جدول الاعمال الامريكي محاوله
للاطاحه بما يقدر بنحو 2000 من قوات فيجنر
الذين دعموا حمله حفتر 2019 2020
للاستيلاء على طرابلس وساعدوا منذ ذلك
الحين في تعزيز قبضته على امدادات النفط
في بلد يضم اربعين في المئه من احتياطيات
افريقيا
لكن الولايات المتحده في وضع غير مواطن في
ليبيا حيث لا توجد لديها قوات ولا وجود
دبلوماسيا حتى الان
اما الكرملين فيدرك ان امريكا تريد اضعاف
نفوذ روسيا في ليبيا كما يبدو ان بوتين قد
استقر على سياسه دعم الوضع الراهن وهو وضع
يحتمل ان يترك صادرات النفط الليبيه
رهينه لروسيا التي تشعر بضغوط العقوبات
على مبيعاتها من النفط الخام
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات